harm sucht hühnerstall aber das ist ein
echtes problem im berliner tierheim
denn es gibt einfach zu viele single
henne der traum vom bio ei aus eigener
haltung immer mehr berliner versuchen
sich als hühnerzüchter ob im eigenen
garten oder sogar auf dem balkon
doch viele unterschätzen die arbeit als
biobauer das tierheim schlug alarm
26 hühner hähne warteten dort kürzlich
auf ein neues zuhause
trauriger rekord die leute sind halt zu
zeiten des corona wahrscheinlich aufs
huhn gekommen es gibt immer mehr firmen
die hühner anbieten für damit die leute
frische eier haben und die leute
überlegen sie war vorher nicht hatten
hohen für bedürfnisse hat man ja einfach
auf dem balkon ist natürlich ziemlich
eng bei den hühnern sieht man natürlich
auch da ist halt das federkleid kaputt
weil zu engem raum die tiere paarten
sich und können sich nicht aus dem weg
gehen können kein sandbad machen also
gefieder pflege ist auch nicht vorhanden
und ja das hat die problematik
doch während die meisten hühner bereits
vermittelt werden konnten bleiben die
hähne im korb
wir haben viele hin hier die halt noch
ein zuhause suchen die heizung händen
suchen wir wissen dass es nicht einfach
ist weil jene halt keinen nutzen haben
die sind halt nur wichtig für die hühner
gruppe an sich aber legen hat keine eier
und um die tiere dürfen halt auch nicht
abgeschlachtet werden und ich verzerrt
werden
dadurch macht uns mit der vermittlung
als sehr schwierig und so wird es
langsam eng im tierheim für die berliner
single hehle die problematik ist wenn
man halt viele hin hat die müssen halt
immer einzeln sitzen bei hähne
untereinander sehr unverträglich sind
gerade wenn auch vielleicht hühner noch
dabei sind dann geht es gar nicht und
die hähne besetzen uns halt die ganzen
hühnerställe und wenn ihr zeit vermehrt
immer hühner kommen haben wir umfang
ihren platz mehr noch mit aufzunehmen
und wir mussten jetzt selbst
aus unterbringen bei unseren in einer
voliere die noch frei war
da sitzen jetzt momentan auch zwei hähne
und ja wir wissen halt nicht mehr wohin
mit den hin
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren